[Music]
there's scientific consensus on a lot of
things on climate change the best
scientists in the world are all telling
us that our activities are changing the
climate on HPV vaccine the majority of
cervical cancer cases are avoidable if
we vaccinate against HPV and that deeply
burying nuclear waste is a good
long-term solution so you would think
that the public could agree on these
issues in many ways one would hope that
that's true right the information that
we learn about science ends up getting
filtered through our prior beliefs
through our values through our religious
views our ideologies and as a result the
exact same piece of scientific
information means very different things
to different people
compliance for mandatory vaccinations is
about 90% in the US but the HPV vaccine
that protects against cancer from a
sexually transmitted virus is only
mandatory in three places you can frame
HPV in two ways you can either see this
as a vaccine against cancer and leave it
at that or you can see it as a vaccine
that as some people saw it as it was
rolled out in Texas and elsewhere that
would lead to promiscuity so why do we
disagree on scientific consensus what's
important to keep in mind here when we
process new information the way we as
human beings do that we put them on
mental shelves I don't look at every
piece of information as if it's the
first thing I've ever seen I basically
have in my head a number of mental
shelves that allow me to quickly
categorize new information so HPV
vaccine the HPV vaccine is a great
example because then I can either put
that on a curing cancer shelf or I can
put that on on a sexual intercourse
among minors or among people who we
think shouldn't have that yet shelf
[Music]
let's see how that works we're going to
introduce you to two composite
characters we're calling them Marcia and
Marie and they are proxies for a whole
bunch of studies that have
look at this issue first meet Marsha
[Music]
she's a working professional
college-educated she has two children
and she's scientifically literate now
meet Marie hi everyone she's a working
professional college-educated she has
two children and is also scientifically
literate they are alike but so different
the government should stop telling
people how to live their lives the
government should put limits on the
choices of individuals so they don't get
in the way of what's good for society
it's not the government's business to
make laws that keep people from hurting
themselves the government should do more
to advance society's goals even if that
means limiting the freedom and choices
of individuals their cultural and
political outlooks on the world differ
and researchers have labels to describe
them Marsha has a hierarchical and
individualist view of the world on
climate change I really don't think
there's a climate problem and certainly
not man-made the HPV vaccine I mean I
don't know why my daughter has to be
vaccinated against a sexually
transmitted virus when she's only 12 and
she thinks it's safe to bury nuclear
waste it's going to be buried very deep
underground I don't see why this Marie's
worldview is egalitarian and
communitarian on climate change of
course climate change is happening and
we humans are making it worse on the HPV
vaccine as soon as I can protect my
child from diseases the better and
unburying nuclear waste I'm really
skeptical about burying it there are
earthquakes happening in places we never
thought
their worldview affects how they assess
risk so cultural cognition is a version
of what's what what we've known in
psychology for a long time as motivated
reasoning and motivated reasoning says
we as human beings don't reason in a
perfectly objective or neutral way
scientific information may be fact-based
or neutral but how we interpret that
information is not we assimilate reality
into our biased worldview we don't
adjust our worldview based on the
reality but we we adjust reality based
on our worldview in fact the more
scientifically literate the more you
stick to your beliefs we protect our
identities it is all about identity
protection if I'm a strong conservative
or strong liberal I don't want facts to
constantly challenge what I really hold
deep down to be true in an increasingly
politically polarized world how do we
fix this problem
you
[Music]